>> So, here's in fact another theorem for you Michael. So, it turns out the
theorem that we wrote down before is
still true in the case of non-deterministic games.
>> Oh, cool.
>> Of perfect information, right? By the
way, do you know whose theorem this is?
>> Charles' theorem?
>> No, although that would be cool.
>> Von Neumann's theorem?
>> Yes, this is von Neumann's theorem.
>> Oh really?
>> Yeah. Did you just guess?
>> Von Neumann, he's responsible for everything.
>> Do you know, well, you going to remind everyone who von Neumann is?
>> He's my uncle?
>> No.
>> No, you're right. You're right. Von Neumann,
so we talk about von Neumann architectures in computer
science, that the basic design of a microprocessor is
still following the ideas that that he worked out.
>> Right, the von Neumann Machine. So there you go. So, this is pretty
good, right? So, what we did, so what did we learn so far? What we
learned so far is, the only thing that matters is the matrix. And once you
have the matrix, you used mini max, at least if you're in a two player
zero sum game of perfect information. At least if you're in a
world of two player zero sum games of perfect information. We can
just write down this matrix, throw everything else away and use mini
max or maxi min and figure out what the value of the
game is, which is the same thing as saying as, we know
what the policy is. The kind of joint policy, in a world
where everyone is being rational and trying to maximize their rewards and
assumes everyone else is doing the same. That's pretty cool, I think.
>> Awesome, so though, you know, I feel like
I could make a matrix that wouldn't have this
property. This maxi min equals mini max. And, and
that we couldn't make a tree out of it.
>> You probably could, but I'm going to guess that
it's going to require that it's no longer zero sum.
>> Nooo, I'm going to say no to that.
>> Well, you know what, I, actually now that,
I think I understand what you mean and the answer
is yes you could. And in fact, that's what we're
going to do next when we relax the next little bit.
>> Ooh.
>> So, would you like
to do that?
>> Sure, though I'm afraid if we get too relaxed, we might just fall asleep.
>> In fact, why don't we do that, why don't we take a nap and then come back?
>> [LAUGH]
the, the joy of being on video, asynchronous napping.
>> Done. Okay, I'll see you in a second.